all right
so half your time and your iido
techniques your
Kon is should be on the ground
okay but you have to do the ground
technique right okay what you're what
you're working on and you are working on
on standing but it works it's easier to
work it or it's there better drill for
more efficient drill to work it seated
so again in the Chinese internal Arts is
called the qua and I'm just going to
keep it simple it's this pelvis area
okay for now and what it's not it's not
your
waist it's not your waist okay you don't
turn your waist in Japanese
arts and you also don't turn your hips
you're not turning your hips I'm not
turning my hips so I don't ever do c
hole like
this I don't do that if you pay
attention the hip is actually going the
other
way this
way I don't go like
this
so we'll take yesterday's
technique and for now I want you to
imagine a few physiological points one
is this hip
crease you're you're always going to
close one as close one as you open the
other close one open the other another
one is another key point is this one
going this way never wrap up my stomach
okay not at my waist it's lower W here
and then the third one is like your
tailbone or your Center gravity dropping
through dropping through to the bottom
dropping through the bottom there okay
so we do that technique yesterday right
so we go
back and the first one you can see it's
ever so slight I not here like
this ever so slight close open andhale
pass him okay and then you're going to
reverse
it close open and then you continue this
one and you'll
do that horizontal
one down you'll
go and you'll do the horizontal one into
that Center gravity one down but you're
closing one
side very much like koku you close one
side on
Kul
so close
open reverse close open you see
turn there's that horizontal crease down
it'll go through the horizontal
crease then close open drop your
Center boom
close
close open
boom
horizontal continue the
horizontal close open Center
drop so watch how I'm doing that
constantly that's why I'm wearing I'm
not wearing the hak so you can see it
so
boom oh all my pow is coming from
there not from my
waist you see that difference not from
my foot
[Music]
Maneuvers boom close close oops
drop thank you very much so you can see
so here's that
crease
close opens this one reverse the other
way
close this one open that
one turn
horizontal that horizontal keep going
down bring and close this
one okay
let's go okay so if I'm here I do one
two two move fold boom back down drop
close that's my movement one two P fold
P
close don't use your
hands it was never in your hands close
that was it close that's it don't pull
back close that's it turn when you turn
you're going to be on the other side of
this arm come to this
side right now it looks like I'm on the
right but when I
turn I'm on the other side and that's
where I
drop here here is that hinge that hinge
is not here it's here oh then you you go
right back into
cesa and you continue that hips drop do
you see and then one more close that's
what makes it K ho it's exactly like K
ho and we're not rotating like how a lot
of people think K ho is so he's pushing
push push that's my Integrity close same
back drop with the F close one more time
then you do it on the other side you
close on this
side okay
ti so we'll simplify more okay so she's
pushing push push push push push push
push and I'm holding that horizontal
seam in place then I'm going to close
this one my arm will not do
anything that's it then I'm going
to open this
one
boom close boom
open open that one you understand so
this is
different that's all my arms moving you
see so we'll leave the throw out and
again Watch what you've been confusing
for Tachi here close that's it then from
the pelvis
okay try
it okay now always in Kona you're
working on different things at the same
time so one yes I'm doing those
seam that qua cultivation
okay Bo then you have my okay so when I
come back I use that seam close this
seam open that seam to get the arm there
but before it leaves the m the perfect
space time I have to turn into it you
understand you can't you can't do like
the last drill you took them too far
into the
technique you're bringing them back from
the initial kazushi into a place where
you can now work on that horizontal line
this one don't don't confuse it with
this the creas is here that's going back
boom boom
boom okay up here there's my crease
that's what it drives in not my hands
the crease my hands are connected to the
crease then it drops that same angle
look at the hip crease it stays exactly
where it is and it
drops then one more crease
closure
boom
back
over
drops one more crease
cor okay on the last
crease this one right there
on the good UK you won't have to do it a
great deal okay CU he'll he he can
already he'll already feel the pressure
he'll already feel it he's already he'll
move with it on the baduk they'll
disengage because they're unconscious
from the throat and you might end up
smashing the heck out of their elbow and
their shoulder into their chin and stuff
okay if that happens only undo the
crease a
little do you see not unconsciously all
the way on the good you you don't do
undo it at all you see it's still that
same crease got it
okay so I have
a b and you'll see I'll let it Loose a
little
okay there it is and she did it for me
okay so I didn't have to un Let it Loose
that
time I'm this part here do not turn your
waist it's not in your waist it's in
this crease and this goes this
way do you understand so you should not
feel pressure in this case on your right
elbow because you're trying to turn your
waight make your arm strong extend it
extend it extend it with all your
power I'm barely getting it
okay on this much smaller person than
me extend your
arm crease it's like she's not trying at
all okay you see
that
so
crease crease throw crease drop
immediately I'm still in that crease you
see I never let it up in that crease
that goes into the technique
then don't turn
this close this crease like you're doing
Cy hole here
boom don't stress your inner arm elbow
bicep area of the upper hand that's
telling you you're turning your waist
that's the wrong power source okay let's
go